I don't have that mental block of like, oh, I got to meet with my boss and explain the
things that I've done this week because I'm responsible for them.
No, it's me.
It's me and me.
Oh, let me call my boss.
Can I get today off?
Yep.
You're off today, right?
That's the truth of it, right?
When I make friends, I do this with my friends.
My boss is really on my ass right now.
My buddies are like, we're hanging out like, hey, can you message your boss?
Can you tell us if you can do this on Friday?
I go, hey, can you get today off?
Oh, wait, I have Friday off now.
Okay, cool.
All right, man.
Ben, thanks for coming on the pod, dude.
We had a little bit of a pre-chat right before this episode and we realized we were getting
lost in the conversation and we said, oh, we got to start the pod.
I think it's a good time to start it.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, exactly.
So, dude, so excited to have you on the pod.
We've been saving you, actually, you know, because when we launched the podcast, we were
like, hey, you know, could we have you on the pod?
And then we realized, hey, let's get a little bit of traction first.
Let's get our training wheels off and then we're ready for the big gun.
So I think we're here.
I think we're ready to roll.
I don't know if I'd like to be called the big gun.
I feel like you guys are putting expectation all the way up here and then I hope I deliver
for it.
But I appreciate it.
I hope I can leave up to the expectations, too.
Well, that's good.
I think it's a shared responsibility.
But, you know, we like to keep the pressure on.
So in line with that, I think we're going to go ahead and start off the episode with a little
story and we're going to flash back to 2022.
This is sort of a memory I have of us sitting together at a table at a hotel in Colorado
at a HackerOne life hacking event.
And I think this was a pretty rough time period in your life.
And you and I were collaborating together and talking about, you know, how to approach
this target and you were feeling a lot of insecurity and not confidence in the bug bounty
journey, which is kind of crazy to me because I, you know, got into bug bounty watching your
videos and seeing your content.
And so I was glad to be able to be there for that time.
But then I look back at that and then I look at now, which is, you know, years later, having
just done a 500k year in bug bounty.
And I just wonder about that journey.
So I was wondering if you could take us back to that spot and then bring us forward to today.
Yeah.
So, I mean, the table you were talking about, it was me.
So me and you and I were working on some projects in the past, non-hacking related.
And then I kind of like ghosted you and I got in person.
I was like, okay, I owe this guy an apology.
So I was like, hey, like, sorry, I had to ghost you guys.
And, you know, there was context to it.
And I think at the time I was actually on the come out of that entire problem.
You know, so I, a lot of people know this.
I was married for a while.
And then before COVID happened, I was, you know, really struggling with depression, anxiety,
a lot of different issues.
And then in 2020, I went through a divorce.
And actually, like, Joel, I think, was one of the first people that found out about the
breakup.
It was just, I think I found out about some stuff in his life.
And then I messaged.
I was like, hey, I heard you're going through some stuff and Christmas is coming up.
What are you doing?
It's like, oh, I'm not going back home.
I'm going to be, you know, in my area.
I was like, do you want to come hang out with me?
We can just hang out.
And I just got a puppy.
You want to come meet my new dog?
And he came up.
And funny enough, we put some furniture together that we broke.
And then I sent it back to the manufacturer.
We don't have a talk about that.
But yeah, I think before I can talk about that, though, there is a little bit to talk
about what got me to 2022 where you and I sat at that table.
Yeah, I'd like to hear that.
I kind of told you about it, right?
And so about 2018, I want to say 2018, 2019 is when I got into content creation.
I started with my live stream.
This is when like the first live recon happened.
I didn't have this beautiful office.
I had a bunch of like Batman courses in the background because, yeah, it was.
But getting banned from Twitch.
Getting banned from Twitch.
Yeah.
A lot of like different crazy stuff that happened.
And, you know, the big thing with, you know, that I also applaud you guys for doing this,
the consistency when it comes down to creating content.
You guys are, you know, pushing out a podcast once a week.
You're doing these calls.
I just saw you guys doing a prep call, you know, before the podcast.
I'm sure you guys spent hours before it.
I want to say for every hour of content that you're making, you're putting into about five
hours of work at least minimum, right?
So now imagine that I'm doing four days of streams a week.
I was streaming Friday, Saturday, Sunday, and Monday.
No way.
This is before we were stuck.
This is before we were told we had to stay at home on Friday, Saturday, Sundays because
of COVID, right?
So I wasn't going out on Fridays in the morning.
I wasn't going out Friday nights because I had to stream on Saturdays.
I wasn't going out Saturday nights because I had to stream on Sundays and I couldn't
go do stuff with family on Sunday mornings because I had to stream.
And when you do that and you're away from family, you're away from doing the things
that you love and you have family members around you that miss you, friends that don't
see you, everyone was like, oh, we can't see you this weekend.
Because you have to stream, right?
That was the go-to with me.
Wow.
So I built up a lot of pressure on external people in my life that they wanted to see
me and I couldn't see them.
And I pushed a lot of pressure.
I couldn't travel anymore.
Yeah.
There's all these things, right?
So I want to pause you.
Go ahead, Joel.
Well, we both have so many questions about this.
We're out of time.
Yeah.
So I was going to say, I have a friend who I know personally.
He was not a streamer and he transitioned into now full-time streaming.
He's been doing it for about a year.
And I've noticed this.
I don't know how much it's affected him, but I was curious what it felt like in the
moment for you.
Because I think like in the moment, it's very easy to just sort of be like, I'm growing,
like things are going really well for this.
I'm putting a lot of time and effort into this.
Like it's working.
I'm just going to keep doing that.
And it's kind of easy to sort of justify the reasons for why the other aspects of your
life sort of start to fall apart.
What was it like, like from your perspective, like going into it, like in hindsight, it's easy
to see like, you know, okay, I'm spending too much time and energy on that.
I probably should have focused on family, but like in the moment, what was it, what was it
like from the inside?
Um, so the thing with me is I have a very addictive personality that I can control.
I can't control when it comes down to like the things that I enjoy doing.
Like I can control when it comes to like drinking and partying and things, I can control that
part.
But when it comes down to like hacking, you know, when you get that high of like success
that you're getting, whether it's content, bug bounties, you know, whatever it is I'm
doing, that is the time that I can't control it at all.
So at first it was bug bounties and I was, you know, I was working full time and I was doing
bug bounties and I took a break.
I was like, okay, now I want to do content.
But when you're hitting success that it's hard to say, no, it's hard to
take a break.
Yeah.
Because, you know, with, with, with hacking, the thing that I really struggled with was
every time I went out to hang out with my friends, that was, you know, six hours of
going out.
And then if I went out drinking three hours of being hungover in the morning, that's about
a nine hour of time that I lost without making bounties.
Right.
Now, if I'm streaming every day, if I miss one day, people do people are quick to forget
you when you start making content.
Yeah.
I've, you know, it's very hard to say no to doing things.
And that's just one aspect of content that I've just talked to.
There's more to how it changes your life, but just from a perspective, like success, it is
really hard to say no.
When you're, when your growth is like, it's not even like slowly going up.
It was just huge.
I had a huge growth with Twitch.
I think I got like 10 to 15,000 followers within a couple of a year.
Wow.
And had a huge community.
I would tweet out, you know, random shit on Twitter and it would get a lot of attention.
And I was just like, holy crap, this is becoming real.
Like people actually like, and with, dude, Twitch has one of the most engaged communities.
It is insane how many people can, you know, support you, have to interact with you.
They want to like be a part of your community.
I've never seen it like that.
And then when you come into that, it's just hard to give up.
It's hard to like, let go.
Right.
So just, you know, taking a pause, you know, there was times when I would take a, like
hacker one would say, Hey, we're doing the H1415, for example, you got to come to San
Francisco.
I would take a weekend off.
But the whole time in my brain, I'm going, please don't drop my numbers when I go back
next week.
Please.
You know, I hope my regularers come back.
I hope my regular reviewers come back, or at least I get the engagement.
So it's really hard to say no to it.
But the other thing that comes with content when you're doing streams is you're showing a
thin link version of yourself.
You cannot hide who you are when you're doing a stream.
And that comes when you're doing technical content.
It's harder.
When I don't know a topic on stream, guess what?
I'm going to look it up.
Those mistakes you made that you're not, you're inefficient.
Everybody sees it and everybody judges you.
That's why people say you don't want to meet your heroes.
Well, it's vulnerable too.
You know, like you're going on there and you know that that's going to happen time and time
again.
All of us know, even the pros that we have to, you know, still Google how to write a
markdown link or like, you know, get the syntax right in a specific thing.
So people don't see it that way.
People thought, you know, I was getting some, some top hackers were like very disappointed
in how I was doing things on streams.
I had messages of people that I call these elite hackers that I distant myself nowadays
that they're like, oh, this is how you do it.
You didn't know how to do it on the stream.
And I was like, no, I kind of know how to do it, but it's like, I'm also teaching things
to people.
So I was doing a lot of like things in a Google sheet, for example, because, you know, people
that was the early days and I didn't want to jump into bash right away.
And people were like, oh, you don't know how to do basic stuff.
And I'm like, which one is it?
Do I teach people or do I come up and be the super lead hacker that knows everything?
Well, even if, even if you don't, I mean, even if you do it a different way, that's
a part of your unique hacker identity too.
You know, there's no, there's no reason why somebody needs to come and say like, Hey, you
don't know, like literally everything about bash.
What's wrong with you?
Because, you know, that knowledge that they spent getting, you know, learning bash, you've
spent somewhere else.
Right.
And then you've got that, that sort of knowledge trade-off on the other side.
Um, and so it's never, never a good idea.
You never like to see people shame other hackers for, you know, lack of knowledge in
some, in some areas.
Cause you'd never know where that knowledge got traded to.
Yeah.
I want to answer your original question.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Well, this, this actually, we had a great discussion about this recently.
Um, and Rezo brought up this XKCD called, uh, I think it's like one in 10,000 or something.
And it's basically like, it's basically, I don't know if this is how real this statistic
is or whatever, but it's basically that like every day, like 10,000 adults, like learn,
uh, something like for the first time.
Um, and if somebody hasn't heard about something for the first time, then they're, they're one
in 10,000, like that they're, you know, they're part of the statistic and just like, that's
okay.
Like that's going to happen.
You're going to be part of that someday too.
Or you already have been.
Um, I think the other aspect of it is like, there's so much emphasis to put nowadays on
like being like a dictionary of things.
And like, I can appreciate that to some extent, but I also think it's equally important to
be able to like use the resources around you to find things without having to like know
it explicitly.
And that's like relying on Google or like relying on your peers or bookmarks or notes or whatever
to like help you find things so that you don't have to, cause your brain can only hold so
much, right?
Like you're gonna, you're gonna have to like start to exchange some knowledge out for other
things and having systems that you can like find that data in an efficient way is just as
important.
And that's, that's one of the things that I think you did great on those streams, Ben,
was like equipping people with the knowledge of how to go and get the information, you know?
Like even, even if you, you know, like you were just talking about, even if you don't know off
the top of your head, oh, what is this syntax?
Well, I'm just gonna open the man page.
Well, some people didn't know about man page and now that you've just equipped them with
that, that way.
And as, as a, um, as a mentor to a couple of young hackers, one of the things I'm struggling
with right now is how do I embed in, in them that confidence that they can go find the technical
piece of information they need to solve their problem, um, you know, without relying on a
mentor.
And, and that's one of the best things that, that, you know, you can do to equip a mentee,
I think.
Um, but yeah, sorry.
So we got a little off topic going back to the question.
The number one, the number one thing that I got on my streams always was it makes me feel
good that a pro like this has to look up the most basic concept in my answer.
Yeah.
That's how it's supposed to be.
Like exactly.
That's how it's supposed to be at all the time.
Right.
And people that tell you, they don't look things up and I had people on my stream when I did
the interviews or like, oh, I know this from the back of my head.
I'm like, cool.
Like you're just storing shit in your back of your brain.
That's yeah.
You're going to use once a year.
I applaud it, but you know, you learn things as you, you do it more and more, but I don't
want to jump into the, I don't want to talk too much about their content piece of it because
I know people want to do all sorts of technical stuff.
But the biggest thing that I, you know, I came across this, um, I came across this bit of a
podcast.
I wish I knew what podcast that was.
I just remembered a message from it that it was, uh, you know, when I was early in the
days of like creating this brand and you know, the name or whatever you want to call it was
if you want to become an online person or you're given two options, those two options are you
either have to, um, fully off yourself and unalive yourself of who you are and create this new
persona and, you know, be this new person that you can put up the charade if you want to call
it and become this person that you are online and live it up, you know, every day, day in and
day out when you're on camera, or you have to amplify the crap of crap out of who you
are personally.
And people are either going to love you for it, or they're going to hate you for it.
And you have to be okay with it.
And I took the approach of just being myself and, you know, being okay with being who I
am.
And I know a lot of people that don't like me for it.
And I know a lot of people that have actually enjoyed seeing me who I am, seen my growth
online and seeing the things that I do.
And that was the biggest change that I applied and it helped a lot with, uh, the personality,
but I want to kind of, you know, I want to answer your question about like what happened
in Denver, but I feel like we'll need to understand the context of what was going on 2018 to 2022
in my life where I had no social life.
I had no, you know, my, my partner at the time was fed up with it and had issues with
her at the time too.
And, you know, I'm just not spending any time with anybody because I want to, I wanted
it bad enough.
Right.
And then get to 2022 COVID happens and, you know, we're locked in now.
I hadn't seen my parents in five years.
I was supposed to see them.
That's not happening anymore.
My brother had a kid.
I was supposed to go see the baby.
That's not happening anymore.
We're locked into the house and there's nothing happening.
And on top of it, I'm going through a divorce while everyone's locked in in the house.
So like, that's the reality of my life at the time.
And luckily by 2022, it's like literally, it's literally when I came out of it.
And you know what the really fucked up part about all of it is?
Like I hosted the home con, I hosted activity con.
I hosted all my streams with a smile on my face while on the inside, there was so many
things that were happening and nobody even knew.
And like I said, Joel was one of the people that knew about it.
Joel came to the house and he could see the state that I was in.
But when I was streaming, nobody knew, dude.
Nobody had a clue about what was happening on the external of like, you know, from the
optics of it.
Nobody knew.
I was still going.
I think during activity con, I think that was in September, a month before it, my old
boss, Luke, you guys both know Luke.
He sat me down.
I was like, dude, you're not acting like yourself.
What is going on?
And that was like, you know, seven months into it.
And I was like, since you're asking me, dude, he's like, you're not acting like yourself.
You're like, you know, short tempered.
That's not who you are.
You're very friendly as you used to be.
You're, you're lacking decision making has been like noticeable.
Like, cause I'm quick to say, this is what we're doing.
I guess how we're going to do it.
And it's like, what's going on?
And I was like, okay, now I'm going to tell somebody.
So I started with him, then, you know, a couple of coworkers and then more friends and
more, you know, more people.
Yeah.
So, so, you know, at that point you were starting to let some of this out.
And, and I know, I think one of the things that is, is tempting as a content creator
is to not let that vulnerability, you know, be seen, right.
Not, not, you know, put on that, that facade, put on that happy face, but it really, it
does, you know, you got to show up as a human.
And each day to these things, but you're also, it'll eat you away, like you were saying.
And I'm wondering, um, you know, in the midst of all this, uh, of these stressors in the
midst of a divorce, in the midst of, um, you know, some depression in the midst of the,
the depression of, or the, um, the pressure of streaming all the time, how did this affect
you as a hacker?
Because before this, you were really, really, you know, going really hard on all these programs
and, and you had had a, oh, did we lose them?
There we go.
Um, before this, uh, you had been going really hard as a hacker and hacking a lot of programs.
But if you're streaming, you know, four days a week and you're not allowed to find vulnerabilities
live on the stream, you know, it's mostly just focused on recon.
How did this, how did this affect your methodology and how did this affect you as a hacker?
So partially one of the reasons, actually one of the videos I'm going to make soon is about
I quit.
I was going to say, I quit, you know, uh, streaming and this is why.
Cause people ask me like, when are you coming back?
I I'm not going to ever go back.
Yeah.
I'm never going to go back to doing live recon probably ever again, because when you're doing
these, like no vulnerability practices every week, what you practice is what becomes your
reality.
Well, you're not.
Exactly.
That's what I'm thinking.
Right.
I'm like, oh no.
Especially when it's like recon and like, I'm one of those people that loves like data,
man.
Like I love looking at, um, these data that I find from companies and like Snoop Dogg and
companies infrastructure.
It's fun.
It's all fun and games, but it's not, it doesn't translate to money.
So I want to do streams.
I'm, I'm thinking about what I get back to making streams and all that stuff, but it's
not going to be the recon stuff because I'm not finding vulnerabilities.
I'm doing the same thing over and over and over again.
I've hit this roadblock and I feel like I know a lot of people that I've learned from
these streams, but I don't want to keep doing that for the new people.
You can go read, well, I'm going to maybe do a couple of them and put them on YouTube
for people to watch, but it's just, you're not finding vulnerabilities and that becomes
your reality of it.
And I kind of want to say ever since I stopped doing it, I've gotten better at with what
I want to do with the hacker, but I also don't want to believe that because I was doing
okay when I was doing those streams.
It's just, I got too comfortable.
Yeah.
I think this is a really common pattern actually that you see.
I mean, I, I can think of multiple cases within the security industry alone where you've
seen this, but people get, they, they get known for a niche and they go, okay, this is my
niche and that that's them for the next 40 years.
And they, that's in any industry, right?
It's not just, right.
Yeah.
Any industry.
It's not even just security.
Right.
But like I, I can think of examples everywhere, including in security where this happens.
And it's really easy because once you become known for something, when somebody goes, Hey,
do you know somebody for this thing?
Your name is going to come up and like, you have like instant recognition.
You have like association with being like a top person within like some certain like pillar
or whatever.
And like, people know your name.
People know that you're like known for this thing, but it's really hard.
One, it's really hard to expand the knowledge.
So like at a certain point, like, you know, there's another XKCD about learning, but it's
like, you know, the, the learning curve is like, you're learning like inverse log,
whatever you're learning like a ton, like right in the first, like, you know, a couple months,
first year or two, whatever.
And then like by year 20, you know, it's like half a percent over the, over the last like
decade.
Right.
And so that same thing is true when you're like focusing, focusing, focusing on some
niche where you're now like an expert in this thing, but there's only so much room for
growth, for knowledge within that.
Like you can maybe do some groundbreaking research.
Maybe there's some, some new stuff to expand on, but a lot of it is like marginal gains
in, in, in overall experience and overall knowledge.
And instead, if you just branch out into something new, you start that curve over again.
And so the key is what you're doing, right.
Which is like, push yourself.
Don't like stick to what's comfortable.
Don't stick to the things that you know, but like take those things, push into new fields
that you're not as familiar with, push into new techniques that you're not as familiar
with so that you can keep yourself on your toes and keep yourself from falling into
that sort of that comfort zone.
And I feel like with recon, it's just rabbit hole after rabbit hole, dude.
It's like, you just find these things you're obsessed about.
And when do you give up?
Like, when do you stop?
Right.
So just automate the boring task.
If you know how to find some vulnerabilities automatically, make them a freaking crone job
and have them just alert you on discord or alert you on Slack and become your, you
know, your, your, your cash cow and learn other things.
It's just, I would be a hundred percent correct.
Or once you become, I was becoming like, you know, I was doing stuff with bug bounties and then
I was becoming very big in recon and I didn't enjoy recon anymore.
It's like everyone that I was like, Oh, when are you doing live recon again?
Oh, I love your live recon.
Like that's the only thing that a lot of people knew me for where, you know, I did a lot of
stuff in the web and I realized with like bug bounties alone, uh, I wasn't making a lot
of money from recon.
I was making money from finding good stuff, but I wasn't making money from automation.
Right.
I had really good data a lot of time.
Yeah.
And that brings me back to one of my favorite quotes that we've had on, on this podcast so far,
which was Jason had except so 12, he said, the point of recon is to find more apps to
hack, you know?
And I think that's, that's just a great point is like at the end of the day, you know, you
can do these recon finds, um, and that sort of thing, but the best bang you're going to
get for your buck is finding apps and then drilling deep into those, uh, those apps and
finding the bugs.
And, and so, yeah.
And in light of that, I kinda, there's two areas where we could go from here.
Um, both which are re related to some content you've released recently, uh, and, and principles
you've been kind of talking about in this, in this, uh, uh, uh, content.
The first of which is the switch from recon to manual.
Um, and, and we've seen this a lot in, in a lot of the different, um, top hackers, uh, where
there used to be a lot more of a focus on, on recon.
Um, and now there's more of a focus on manual hunting as you were making that switch, you
know, in the mid, in the middle, you know, so did this switch occur in 2022 when you were
coming out of that scenario, or is this something that happened a little bit later and how did
that transition occur for you?
The transition didn't really happen because of like the, the content so much, like the, the,
the streaming was a big part of it.
Right.
Yeah.
It just happened.
I needed a change.
Like it wasn't just with hacking.
I needed everything to change.
So I, I was changing my personality to some extent, my, you know, my, my appearance, I go
into the gym and like dieting and things like that, my hacking style, like everything that
I did, I just wanted to recreate who I was as a person.
And even though my personality isn't my, you know, hacking, but hacking was a part of my
personal online.
That's what it is.
And I really had to figure out what I wanted to do.
And I sat down and went through all of my reports.
Well, how was I making so much money between the years of 2015 or 2014 and 2018?
Well, a, I wasn't a manager.
I wasn't a senior manager at HackerOne.
That took a lot of time, but B, I was just niching down in one single program.
At the time it was Airbnb, a couple of the private programs, but a lot of times, and then
I looked at the recon bugs that I was finding.
The recon bugs I was finding wasn't so much of having nowadays like nuclei templates and
things that were automated.
It was just like, I was the first to find an asset or I was the first to, you know, find
a functionality or even like I found an asset that people just looked over, but it was just,
you know, people knew about it, but no one found vulnerabilities in them.
Those were my strengths.
And with bug bounties, I really want to tell people like the biggest things you have to
find what your strengths are.
There is no wrong and right with what you do.
If your strength is to be really good at recon, then that's your, that's your niche.
Good for you.
You have to go do that.
But if you're, you know, you want to be a web app hacker, you want to be good at, you
know, breaking apart vulnerabilities in a web application.
If you're good at, you know, previous bugs, there's nothing wrong with that.
That's what you're good at.
And some people are shit at it.
You should be okay with that.
And I had, you know, behind it, being a top hacker, I had a problem with like, well, I
don't want to be this person that's not, you know, doesn't know these vulnerabilities,
but I don't want to be the elitist anymore.
I don't want to be this like top hacker.
I just want to make money, make, do something I could do, you know, good with and teach people
how I do the things that I do.
So now I make the content of things that I enjoy doing and if people want to watch it,
perfect.
And if they don't, they don't.
I no longer care to justify being a top hacker anymore.
Right.
That's become so easy now.
Yeah.
No, that, that's awesome.
I had a lot of this with mobile hacking as well, where like for a long time I associated
and a lot of like my identity was associated with like being the mobile hacking guy.
And like, that's cool.
Like it was awesome for a while, but then I grew to a point where I was like, I want to
be doing more than that and kind of for like the same reason you were talking about.
Like I didn't want to fall into this niche where like that just became like the only thing
I did.
And like, I don't think, I think mobile hacking is probably big enough where it's not like
a small niche, you know, where like you could still probably make a ton of money and there's
like a lot of research and stuff you can do there.
But I just want like, I felt like there was just more that I, I could be doing.
And so I started to like push away from that, but it was such a rough learning experience
because like I had been used to like, you know, things coming very easily with like all
the mobile hacking stuff.
Cause I've been doing it for so many years.
And then it was like starting this, this different type of hacking.
And I was like, oh, wow, this is like running into a brick wall.
Like what, what, what do I even do?
Like, and just like, it really like took me for a loop because it was such a learning
experience of like adjusting my hacking flow and how I was approaching things to be less
targeted towards like what I was used to and more targeted towards things I wasn't.
I think the biggest thing that people like, I feel there's a, when, when you become, when
you get into hacking, I think everybody wants to make it to a certain point, right?
You made it with mobile hacking.
Justin, you have done a bunch of stuff.
I can't even name one for you, but you have gone through these phases of doing things,
right?
But everybody at some point is going to hit a blockade of things they do with their niche.
You hate, you know, you hit it with mobile.
You didn't enjoy it or you learn everything about it.
Whatever the reasoning was, I think pivoting as a whole for us as humans, we got to solve
what we do in our life, in our careers, with hacking, with whatever we do in life, pivoting
is a huge thing.
And a lot of people don't want to do that.
That includes me.
I have a hard time going out of my comfort zone, but since I've started pivoting to different
areas, whether it's with my content, making inspirational content, technical content,
whether it's doing apps I never hacked on before, collaborating with new hackers, putting
myself out there, it's worked out because that's a part of who you are.
That's a part of it, right?
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
And I want to double click.
I actually wanted to go ahead, Joel.
No, you go ahead.
No, no, no.
You were ahead because I was going to turn this a whole other way.
I was going to say, I want to double click into that for just a second and talk about
a little bit how you did that from a technical perspective.
So I know, you know, largely recon and web oriented, you know, in the beginning.
And then now you're kind of pivoting a little bit over this past year.
You mentioned that you found some vulnerabilities in desktop apps and other contexts.
How did you, how did you cut your teeth with that?
How did you get into it?
Well, I was pushed into it, right?
So two of the instances, one of them was the LA event.
We can't talk about the company.
That was a big event, right?
And there was a small web portion of it, but most of it wasn't web.
Exactly.
And that forced my hand.
I didn't know anything about that niche of like hardware hacking at all.
That forced my hand to learn stuff or in mobile hacking as an example.
I didn't know a whole lot about mobile hacking.
I knew a little bit about like, just, you know, what you can do with a mobile app.
You just, you know, intercept your traffic and that's it.
But I never did more than that.
That really pushed my hand to do more, right?
But then I found zero bugs at that event.
I showed up, I refused to do the web stuff.
You know, I was like, no, no way I'm going to look at the web stuff.
And then I realized people were making money from the web, you know, portion of it, which
is fine.
But then the London event happened.
And this London event was another two programs that everybody says looked at them for years
at a time.
But there is a reason why they're doing a life hacking event.
These companies aren't doing a life hacking event for no reason.
There is more to hack on.
There's definitely more vulnerabilities.
Absolutely.
And me, as someone who has been at almost every life hacking event with these companies, I've
learned there's always about two to six thousand dollars, two to six hundred thousand dollars
of bounties coming out every freaking time when these companies come back, right?
And it happened again.
Those companies paid about, you know, a million dollars in bounties.
So those pushed me.
And I was like, okay, if everybody's going to look at this London event that one of the
customers, everyone's going to go after their web applications and everyone's going to
struggle with finding easy wounds, how do I change that approach, right?
How do I find these cool bugs within the context of a desktop app?
Yeah.
Those are the reasons why it pushed me, right?
So when you're looking at, so in this scenario, you decided to go after the desktop app.
And you said, okay, I'm going to start looking into this.
I know you ended up teaming up with Shmuel as well.
And Alex Chapman, two people that have, you know, that are pro in the desktop app space.
How much of that was, would you say, collaboration-based stuff versus you just kind of sitting down,
cutting your teeth on desktop apps, reading as much documentation as you can, versus like
combining multiple different skills from different hackers together, you bringing your web expertise,
them bringing their desktop expertise and creating a wonderful result.
Funny enough, the collaboration didn't happen until the last four hours of that event entirely on day
two. So I have this vulnerability in this desktop app. I couldn't exploit it. We couldn't figure out
what to do with it. I'm sitting out inside looking at the door. It's me, a couple other hackers,
and God bless his soul, Sam Curry, the LZ, is sitting right next to me. And he's like,
you guys know how Sam is. He's very quiet. He just makes, he has these comments he makes very
random. Right. So I'm sitting here. I'm like, dude, I know I can RCE this bug, but I don't know
what I'm doing. Like I have this bug. We don't know what to do. I think you were maybe at the
table too. I don't know. Yeah, I was around. And then you say something about, well, why don't you
go find someone to work with? And then Alex is walking in at this time. Alex Chapman is just
literally walking. Shmuel is sitting right here next to me. And then Sam goes, yeah, Alex is walking.
Why don't you go talk to him? Maybe I bet you he can exploit it. I go and do that with Shmuel and we
explain it. And I think I put Sam on that bug for like a five or 10%. Yeah, of course.
But the point of the story is like, it wasn't like the collaboration was planned. I was working
on a bunch of different vulnerabilities. You know, I've, you know, I found stuff like,
so the back to the story for this customer was, there was a lot of CSP limitations. You couldn't
bypass CSP a lot of times. And this is within the desktop app, right?
Yes. Yep. But also on the desktop, on the web, on the mobile, on the core web app of this company,
there's a CSP that no one could bypass. I found the way to bypass the limitations,
which I can talk about a little bit, but I kept finding these like HTML injections. Like I could
insert hyperlinks and then I would do SMB tricks, but I couldn't because, you know, you can use only
one slash. If you do two slashes, it wouldn't work, right? So I have all these, I have all these
different vulnerabilities, but I can't explore a single thing, except I find a bypass within the
desktop app or in the mobile app or even the web app that you could do a meta refresh, but instead
of doing two slashes, you can do a backslash, backslash, and your Chrome browser or your browser
actually translates that to slashes. So the limitation of doing two slashes with SMB, you can't do two
backslashes with SMB to do an SMB connection for an RCE. Right.
So by doing a meta refresh, you can do a backslash, backslash site.com and it refreshes the entire
webpage to another one. In the context of a web app, doesn't worth, isn't worth anything, right?
Right.
But in the context of a desktop app, you can now control that entire desktop app that you're working
on and you can do whatever you want with it. And we need to, we want to go to the next phase of it.
And just having that bypass is what made it sweet. I know three other hackers who had that
vulnerabilities that couldn't exploit it and no one reported it, except one of them was like,
Hey, I knew this, can we collaborate? And we collaborated with him. And then Chapman was able
to exploit it fully.
Wow, dude, that's amazing. So, so to recap that there, you're finding an HTML injection inside of
the, the desktop app. I don't know. I imagine it's like an electron app or something like that.
And then, and then you're, you're using that HTML injection along with a meta tag to refresh and
use backslashes into the slashes. Now you're on your attacker controlled page inside of the app.
And now you've, you've gained control of the application. And then Mr. Chapman took it from
there.
Yeah.
And those are the things that I talk about, right? Like, you know, there were so many HTML
injections that you can, you can have HTML injections on this app, but nobody, for some
reason thought about the, the meta refresh. The problem with the slashes on this particular
app was you can't do URLs because a double slash translates to a URL, a website to them.
So they didn't allow it. The backslash would save their ass. So that was a, you know, the example
of saying pivoting, right? It's okay. This web application, I had a web app bug that got paid really,
decently. It was a cool bug, but this, this particular one was the highest bounty
I've gone to a live hacking event, I feel like.
Wow.
Right. And it's just pivoting from, I think it was, I want to say it was a 40K bounty.
Yeah.
They didn't want to give us, they didn't give us credit card, they gave us high because
we couldn't prove full RCE, but they knew it's exploitable and they, you know, they honored
it as a high. But that's the, the point of pushing yourself out of your boundaries, right?
It's just going, okay, I know web, I know there's electron apps are pretty much like web
applications, but you have more, there's more impact if you can exploit them than a, you know,
the traditional XSS and if there's CSP in place, you have the ability of using other functionality
that's not, you know, XSS particular.
So I guess, I guess in this scenario, the thing you were talking about that allowed you
to get around CSP, that was the MetaConnect thing. There wasn't some other thing that allowed
you to get around CSP or, okay.
It was just a MetaConnect because now you can point it to another website that you control,
you can put whatever you want on there. And if you have, if you have XSS and if you have
JavaScript in that context for an electron app, it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter where the JavaScript is being executed from, as long as you need, you know,
you're calling the right functions to download and execute a file, right?
Wow. That's awesome, man. So, so you used HTML to redirect the whole page and that's pretty
much the, the only thing I can really think of that does that is the MetaTag. The only other
thing that I can think of is maybe the, like with an iframe, you know, getting able to iframe
another page in and then execute it, but then that wouldn't be the top level page. It would be a sub page.
Correct. So, um, we can do hyperlinks, but when you do a hyperlink also, sometimes it opens up an
actual web browser, right? Cause those are the things that I looked at. I was like, okay, what if I make
a hyperlink? But no, the easiest route was the SMB stuff. You just do an SMB to your box and then
that's like automatic RCE usually, but none of that was working. And I really wanted to, I really,
this was like one of the first live hacking events that I was actually participating. It's my like second or
third at this point. Right. And I really wanted to find something cool. Um, and just pushing myself
to out of, out of my comfort zone. It's not super out of your comfort zone, but it's just,
I don't know anything about electronics at this point. I don't know. I'm not really no big on
JavaScript either. Like I'm just learning things as I go, but just doing that, it just opened up a whole
different world for me, dude. Yeah, no, that, that totally makes sense. So the last question I had
with regards to that is like, and I don't know if you can talk about it without giving away too many
details, but I'm wondering where your, your source was for this, you know, your sync, you know,
obviously you're, you're manipulating the Dom inside the app. Um, but in a desktop application
context, uh, you know, how are you passing data into the app? Is this something that you,
you put into the web application and then it popped up in the, in the desktop app, or is this like a
scheme, a custom URL scheme that they registered or what? No, it was actually one of your user details
that showed up on the app a lot. Um, so you could put your, I don't know what it was. It may have
been like a signature or username or whatever, your name or something like that. Right. One of the,
one of the profile attributes we'll call it. Right. And it was coming up in this specific page, but, um,
it was only in this page that it would actually pop with the HTML. So a lot of times, like, you know,
I don't think that I see with XSS is people are quick to jump to an alert, right? Everyone's just like
image source alert, right? My go-to isn't that my go-to is just a underline H1 test one, two, three.
Yep. Just because I want, I want HTML injection. I don't care because once you have HTML injection,
opens up a whole different world of things you can do, whether it's mobile, whether it's web,
whether it's, uh, you know, just, uh, these, uh, binaries, for example, desktop apps, right?
I just care about the HTML injection. Yeah. So seeing that pop was step one. Okay. Now you go to the
mobile, you go to the web app, you go from the web app to the desktop app. Is it also vulnerable here?
But then that connected me to a bunch of different things because then I also realized some of the
things I wasn't rendering on the web app was rendering in the desktop app as an HTML tag, right?
Wow. Okay.
That opens up a lot more. Same thing with mobile. You, you put something, so many of the bugs that
I found this year were exclusively only popping up on this mobile application and not on the web,
this web version of it. Wow. Yeah. So I was going to ask like,
sort of how this speaks to sort of your, your overall hacking methodology. Um, and, and I think
this is maybe a good time to start to like, talk about sort of like how you approach targets. I'm
sure you've talked a bunch about this on your, on your streams and stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Never. Yeah.
Talk about hacking. I don't think you've ever done that. Um, but, uh, but like, it sounds like a lot of
it sort of comes from very like simple, straightforward testing, right? Like underline H1, ASD123,
like, look, just spray and pray. And like, how, how much further than just like that payload are you,
are you testing before? Like, obviously when you see something that's like HTML injection,
you're going to follow up on that, but how much are you modifying your payloads? Like how, how much
will you test one field? Like do you spend all day on one page or what, how fast are you switching
between stuff? Can you walk through that a little bit? Depends. Yeah. So a lot of times, like, I think it's
pattern recognition. I think like 900% of bug boundaries is, I don't care what you say is
pattern recognition. You, you identify a pattern of mistakes, the particular company, and you just
exploit the shit out of it. That's what it is. That's the reality of it. Right? Yeah. So if I
know a company is, you know, um, good, I know that excess is a big part of like the issues, then I'm
probably spending more time fuzzing specific fields, but it's, I don't change the, the input
that I put in that often. It's, it's one thing that I put, it's like a couple of the different
quotes, different encrypt and different, um, uh, HTML entities or something like that. For example,
it's just a bunch of different characters that I put in as a polygon, for example, and I put it in
there and I analyze or overanalyze the shit out of it until I move on to the next field. But a lot of times,
I'm trying to explain how to say this. So it's the same payload until it fires up. Right? Then what
you do next is different based on the target, based on your end goal, what you're going to do with it.
Like you want to, you want to do an XSS or maybe you can push into the PDF, for example, or maybe you
can push this into some server side stuff and become the blind XSS. Then that objective changes. Right?
But a lot of times it's the same payload that I put in just to see how the application is going to react
to my user input. That, that, that's really interesting because testing those behaviors,
there's, there's like this concept of a poly, like a benign polyglot payload, right? Cause if you look
up XSS polyglot, you'll kind of see, you know, all sorts of JavaScript URLs and, you know, weird comments
and texts, different ways to write script. Yeah. Exactly. And those I don't use. Yeah. That's not what
I use though. I'm saying just, just, uh, I make my own. It's like my own homemade few tags, few
characters, things that I know is going to break out of an input field. It's going to break out of
a script tag. It's going to break out of a text area. It's going to break out of X, Y, and Z. And
then looking at the DOM, I spent a lot of time chasing those. The reason why I do like test one,
two, three, four is because I chase that taste one, test one, two, three within the DOM and see where
it all shows up. Right? Yeah. That's a lot of things that if you just put like a, if you just put test,
test not an easy thing to chase, but if you do test one, two, three, four, something very unique to you,
then it's easier to follow up. Yeah. That's great. And it really makes sense on, on why you would do
the, you know, benign payloads, but also have the polyglot. So it is a really good exercise for the
listener, you know, it to go look at what the polyglot payloads are out there are doing in particular and
why they have to be as complex as they are, and then simplify them down to, to make a, a polyglot
that works only in the HTML injection context that doesn't have the goal of cross-site scripting.
Because the first step to getting cross-site scripting is getting HTML injection in, you know,
X, X amount of the scenarios, obviously you've got to account for the location based, uh, syncs or
whatever. But, um, I think that's a really, a really great piece and, and it, you know, it not using a
polyglot and just using double quote H1, you're going to miss stuff, you know, and if you use the polyglot,
you're going to miss stuff. So you got to find that nice, sweet, sweet spot where you're not getting
too verbose and you're not being too simple either. But there's also two things to that. One is if you
put like, you know, very obvious HTML tags, sometimes it gets filtered. So the objective
isn't just to get HTML injection in there is also to break out of whatever current context you're in.
Because there's going to be times where I put my payload in and it breaks out, but the filtering
takes out some of the HTML or the filtering actually helps me break out of it because it's taking things
out and putting it together or replacing or whatever. It's converting it, it's replacing,
converting it. Right. So that's a big part of it. But I also want to, you know, you know,
I want to really kind of like caution people of this also, like when you put something like a script or
if you put event handlers in there, it might just strip out the entire string you gave it by default.
It'll say, Oh, I see, I see bad. I'm going to take it all out. Right. So that's why the reason why I do it is
the particular order, particular way, just to see, can I break out of this before I even think about
exploitation? Can I break out of this thing that hints to me like, Hey, this is a vulnerability
here and look at it. I was, I was thinking this kind of goes back to what I was, well, I was gonna
say this kind of like the, the whole like dictionary encyclopedia thing I was talking about. And you
mentioned rabbit holes as well. Like, I feel like all these things sort of play together where it's so
easy to like fall down an infinite rabbit hole of just like, you could test every possible, every
payload, everything on one field and you can do that for every single field. But you have to draw
the line somewhere. Do you have like a spot where you draw that line? Like, where do you, where you
decide, okay, I think this is like enough testing on, on this settings panel or whatever.
I feel like by the dictionary, by the definition of the dictionary, I may be considered as insane
because a lot of times I keep repeating the same thing. That's not like doing anything for me.
And then like suddenly it works because you know, like it didn't work three months ago and now it
works only because they made a change in the code. Right. So I feel by definition, I may be a little
crazy, but I don't have a, you know, I sound like I'm sitting here going, oh, I spent like four days on
this thing because I feel like one, there's, there's your instincts, right? This is, I know there is
something here, right? Like you, you, you have this instinct that like, it comes after years of
experience that you go, I can feel there's something here. And then you, maybe you don't
exploit it and somebody else does. Right. And you go, fuck, I could have done that. Or I should
have done this. I should have done this for it. So I, for that reason, I spent a lot of time. It goes
back to my, my personality of being like addicted to wanting to do these specific way. But then that's
why I get burnt out sometimes. It's because I was paying spending, you know, countless days on the
same thing over and over and over again. And then suddenly I have this, my ADHD kicks and it's
like, okay, let's jump around a little bit. So no, if there is, if there is a particular like portal
or a settings page or something that looks really fishy, I'm going to throw a bunch of things at it.
So my thing goes, I'm going to try everything I know, everything I know in the dictionary,
you know, in my, in the books and my tricks and my sleeve, everything I try. Then I, I shit out
with my inner circle, right? If I'm not collaborating with them a lot of times, you know, if I'm doing
something solo, then I go, yo, I found this thing. I think Justin has gotten a bunch of like
random shit. Even you draw like random stuff over time that I'm like, dude, I smell Yvonne here.
Like, can you look at it? And then they throw me ideas, right? Like they give you things that you
didn't think about, or it may be like an idea. And then I do that. Then it's when I go, okay,
I'm going to open source this. And I go on Twitter, I go, I have this thing. I think you've seen like
a bunch of times I tweet these things. I go, I'm fighting this thing. These are the things I've tried.
Give me your best shot. And then people give me ideas. And then I just give up at some point.
Yeah. But I have to go through that list to make sure I've covered it because a lot of times
I've learned with the life hacking events, I look at it, I go, well, son of a I could have,
I should have tested that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I will say nowadays it's great because during the show
and tell I'd say like earlier on in the live hacking cycle, I would see the show and tells and I'd be
like, oh, I should have tested that thing. But like, I just didn't. And like, that's why I missed it.
Now it's like, I should have tested that thing. And there's no way in hell I would have tested what
they just tested to get that bug. So good on them. But also the other thing is like, but for me also,
the other thing of it is that sometimes I see and I go, well, good for them. At least somebody figured
it out or in this bug, whatever, right? Like I said that, I go, damn, I should have tried that.
But then at least somebody figured it out. Right? Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. For sure. So,
so from there, I kind of want to continue in going down this path of hacking methodology. And then we'll,
we'll bounce around a little bit into some technical stuff and to some, uh, I guess,
bug bounty related statistics. But, um, so basically what you, what you just said,
it sounds like you're a little bit more of a thorough hacker. We, we, one of the questions
we ask a lot on the pod is like, how soon do you jump around before you, you know, if you haven't found
a bug, how long do you give a program? Um, and so it sounds like if you're throwing your whole hat
of tricks at it, you know, it might take a little while. Is that accurate or.
It honestly depends. Um, it all depends on my workload, to be honest. Like it depends on what
I got going on that week. So there's times when, you know, when like a life hacking event, there is no,
there's no giving up because it's a life I can give it coming up. There's a lot, there's a lot for grabs.
And then it's like a personal event that I'm like, I need to make this work. I want to have a bug. I want to
you know, contribute to this event. Right. That's a different story. But with like, with the programs
that I have, I become very selective. I just, I select programs that I know a it's going to pay
me enough. It's going to be worth the, you know, the, the three days of not finding goals or three
weeks of not finding goals on going down this rabbit. Dammit. Sorry. I like that it has its own
like effect for it. It's like when my camera dies, it's not nearly that cool. It just dies.
Yeah. For companies that have not figured out how to get this out of idle for every 30 minutes.
That's hilarious. Yeah. For those of you listening, his camera is going off, you know, into
rainbow mode every once in a while. Yeah. But yeah, it all depends. Like, you know, it depends on,
depends on my workload, but with live hacking events, there is no stopping. And then there are times where
a company comes up that I really want to hack on. Right. So I'll give you an example. I got asked to do a
presentation for this company. I have a web app, mobile app, desktop app. And I had a month and a
half to prepare for it, but naturally I was traveling, live hacking events, life, whatever.
I have a week that whole week. I did not stop until I found the phone the night before
the presentation. Yeah. There's no stopping until that goal happens. I don't have a,
I wish I had a good way of saying, this is where I draw the line. It all comes down to my workload. If
I know that tomorrow I have to make content, the next I have to do X, Y, and Z, and then I have to
travel to somewhere else, I'm probably going to give up within the, you know, my, when my first
three days are up. Like I spent two, three days on this app, nothing happens, time to move on,
time to cut my losses. But if it's an, if it's a company that I've hacked on in the past, I've had
good results with, then I pushed out more and more because I know I've gone a bounty from this
company before. I know that pattern's a mistake. I'm willing to spend more time because I know the ROI is there.
Yeah. Yeah. That, that, that makes a lot of sense. You know, when you've established
in a relationship with the company and even three days is, is pretty long for, uh, some of the
researchers that we've talked to where, uh, what did I always think Douglas is hilarious. Douglas is
like, if I don't find a bug in like three hours, then I normally just move on. And I'm like, what the
heck are you like, what are you doing, man? It's like, yeah, I have like three hours a day.
Yeah.
It's a thing though that, that, that depends on the three days. Cause the three days isn't like I'm doing eight hour days.
Right. It's, you know, the first day I'm doing, you know, the first four, you know,
the way I look at it is like the first four hours is really like, what the fuck am I doing?
Exactly. Yeah.
Yeah.
What is this app? What am I supposed to do? What are the patterns of mistakes? I'm just plugging
things in and just observing and like taking in everything that the application does. The second
day is like, okay, now you're really, now you're getting, I'm getting pissed off. Right. And then I'm
going to go a little bit harder to find, I'm going to like extend my attack surface as we call it. Right.
That's great. Then the script is like, okay, dude, like either I fucking find something today
or I just don't, I give up. I'm fucking done. I feel like you guys have seen this in a lot of
inner groups, right? He's pounding the table too. It's so funny. Yeah, dude, a hundred percent. And I
think it's funny you mentioned four hours. Cause that's kind of, that's exactly the same length of
time that I always, a lot for, for that first little bit is like, all right, the first four hours or so,
I'm just trying to figure out what this app does, how to use it, you know, reading the documentation,
stepping through it. You know, I have no expectations of finding bugs within the first
four hours of hacking. And then after, after that, you know, it, like you said, the stage is going to
need to grow where it's like, if I haven't found anything by day three, I'm like, you know, really
having a vendetta against this app. Um, so that's, that's hilarious that we're, we're both sort of on
that same front. So there's, I looked it up online. It's the, there's four stages of anger. It's
annoyed, frustrated, hostile, and enraged. I don't get to enraged unless it's required. I just looked
it up. I stopped at the third level. So, and I think it kind of described it pretty well at this
point. So, uh, yeah, so, so actually I want to go back and talk about that because you said, you know,
sometimes you're working for four hours. Um, I struggle, especially with having another thing,
right. Having the podcast to, to, cause I need contiguous time. I need, you know, long periods
of time where I can stay focused and hack. I can't hack for an hour, then go do something,
then come back, hack for an hour, then go do something, come back, hack for an hour. Um,
do you have that same experience and how do you balance hacking with content creation? Like,
do you lot certain days of the week or do you, do you, you know, just hack after a certain time
or how does that work? Yeah. So a day, a day in life, for no harm's sake.
A day in life for me is like, usually I, you know, like I wake up, I do my,
they think, so funny enough, I don't consider hacking something that takes a lot of brain power
because I feel like once you sit on your computer, you're an autopilot, right? Like,
you know what to do, you know, you know, you, it's your, it's the comfort thing for me. I get
comfortable with hacking. Right. Yeah. So morning is like all the calls, all the meetings, you know,
working with the, with the stuff that I'm building, working on content, you know, emailing,
community, whatever you want to call it. Right. That's what I do in the mornings. It's my first,
you know, eight to noon, maybe eight to two sometimes. Then at about two o'clock is when
I want to switch. So I go to the gym usually for about an hour. Then I come home, maybe take an hour
off. I mean, I go to like a hot, my hot tub or shower. Yeah. Hot tub spot. Let's go.
I feel like I'm the only hacker without a hot tub. Why don't you come over and we'll redo this
episode at one point from my hot tub. This has got one. I love that. All right. Love that.
We'll do hot tubs. But I have a disconnect of a, of a shift in my, you know, in my brain,
I shift it over to something else, whether I'm doing a pen test, I'm bug bounty hunting or whatever.
That's the case for like my regular days. That doesn't include life hacking events, but a lot of times
you'll see me do like get all my meetings out of the way, two o'clock, three o'clock, go to the gym,
come back and switch over to hacking because it's just easier. And then I can, you know, I can have
stuff happening. I'll, you know, I'll make food and, you know, do something and then go back and
forth for like, you know, four to six hours a day. But there's also times when you're getting success
that makes it harder though, right? Like there is tape. There's, when I hit those huge bug bounty
month that I was doing, there was no boundaries at all. It was eight o'clock. I was waking up.
I was doing bug bounty things like for two hours, then doing calls, meetings, going to the gym,
coming back, doing it. And I just, you know, I'm just going stir crazy because I'm so hyped over it.
Those are the edge cases, you know, life hacking was an edge case for it. But typically I try to
have that shift where I do my day work, just get all the boring tasks out of the way.
Everyone's awake, you know, Adam, I work with his in London. So I have to wake up early to work with
him sometimes people that want to, you know, people want to, people have nine to fives. I want to meet
with you. They're not going to meet with you and you know, they want to meet with you in the morning.
So prioritize those. And then I do that. You have to have that mentality shift.
And I also surprisingly don't even hack out of this room. This is purely meeting content,
whatever. I like to sit crisscross applesauce, headphones in on the couch. I don't care whether
something's on the TV or not, but no, I have to sit on the couch comfortably with my feet,
like crisscross and just sitting there in like a position where I'm comfortable and just hacking from
the couch. I agree. I was, I was going to say that I had a couple of things I was going to say,
but like, that's true for me too. Like I find it, even though I have like this really nice setup,
it's very difficult for me to like feel comfortable hacking when I'm like in such a structured
environment. I feel like a lot of the time, the best hacking that I do is when I'm just like sort
of on the fly, like ad hoc, I'm just sitting next to somebody or I'm just like chilling and I'm just
like, got my laptop pulled out or whatever. And I'm just like fiddling with stuff.
Yeah. That's awesome. The other thing I was going to say was how do you, how do you manage like the
the energy aspect of it? Because you mentioned like you start hacking at like three o'clock
after like a day of like meetings and whatever and stuff for me, I can be totally drained by three
o'clock. And like, that's very difficult to, to keep up the energy level and sort of like the mental
stamina to keep pushing after sort of like that hump in the day. Yeah. Do you have like
hacks that you use personally to get over that or, or how do you, how do you, it depends on the day,
right? Like you are going from a, your daytime job where you have, I'm sure you have somebody to report
to and people that report to you, you have responsibilities that the, the structure of a
corporate job is different than when you work for yourself. I feel like, because I don't have,
except for a couple of people that work with me on my team, I don't have to manage them, right?
They have their projects. I do my part. They do their part. We're good. Right. I don't have that
mental block of like, oh, I got to meet with my boss and explain the things that I've done this week
because I'm responsible for them. No, I it's me, you know, it's me and me. Oh, let me call my boss.
Can I get today off? Yup. You're off today. Right. That's the truth of it. Right.
When I make friends, I do this with my friends. Like, can you, can you do this?
This is really on my ass right now. But my buddies were hanging out like,
hey, can you message your, can you tell us if you can do this on Friday? I go, hey,
can you get today off? Oh wait, I have Friday off now. Okay, cool. That's the, that's a good
thing about working for yourself. Right. So, but it doesn't mean, it doesn't mean that I don't have
the days where like I have, you know, back to back meetings and then I have a really hard day and I
don't want to hack. I have those days and I go, eh, whatever. I'm not going to hack today. Like it happens.
Yeah. And that's, yeah, that's the nice part about being.
Life eating events are not included in that.
Yeah. No, no, no. Those are different animals. That's the nice part about being self-employed
and particularly full-time bug bounty is I feel like if you're good enough at bug bounty, you can
do that. Right. Because you're making enough money to say like, hey, actually really don't feel like
hacking today. And that was one of the mistakes I made earlier on in my, in my full-time bug bounty career
was like, I was like getting on my own ass every single day. If I wasn't out there, you know,
hacking stuff. And then Mariah tells me one day, she's like, Justin, you don't need to,
you know, if you don't feel like hacking today, just take the day off, you know, and, and come back
at it when you love it. And when you're inspired by it and when you're, you know, hyped for it and
you're going to get way better results. Um, which I think is really true. And I'm glad, uh, you know,
you've learned that lesson and, uh, it seems like from the way that you've described it, you have,
you've managed the stress aspect of having the content and the hacking together really well,
which is something I'm still, I'm still trying to, uh, to be gentle with yourself, man. Like only you
know what internally you're going through. I'm sure with like, Mariah knows a lot of it, but you know
what's going on inside, right? There are days when I just, even with life, I can give it sometimes I go,
you know what? Fuck it. Worst is I don't find anything. Like I have to be okay with it.
Yeah. It's not an easy shift. So when I went from a daytime job to working for myself, it was really
hard because how do you, what is the, how do you measure that? Right. How do you measure success with
not working a nine to five? Right. It's really hard because you know, you go, oh, if I don't make
money, who do I blame? What if I make more money? Right. It's just, you have, you're the only one that
is responsible. So you also have to have that relationship with yourself to be able to say, you know what,
today was a rough day and I just want to hang out and like watch movies or I just want to play video
games or whatever that is. Yeah. My thing is a lot of times I try not to, so when I'm doing like these,
I go through these sprints, right? I tried to do like, I go, I'm going to do, I'm going to go grind
out bug bounties for a while and then I'm going to be done for it. During those times, I tell myself
like by eight o'clock, nine o'clock, try and at least like disconnect and go play some video games or
watch a movie, watch a TV show or something. So I'm like about like eight 30, nine o'clock, if my friends text me,
like, Hey, call it duty tonight. Fuck it. Yeah. I'm going to get on and play games with him.
A hundred percent. You have to be okay with having those because if you're not doing that,
um, then that's how burnouts happen. Like the reality of it is it's going to happen.
What about weekends? Do you work on weekends or do you, do you mostly take weekends off?
Um, I don't have a concept of working. I've, I've tried to get rid of the concept of nine to five and
weekday weekends. If I feel like Saturdays are the day I kind of do stuff. It's like I catch up on
some stuff. Sundays. No, I don't work because I tell myself you need one day for yourself and it's
not to not work. I still work on Sundays. I make my thumbnails and like I print videos on Sundays,
but it's not, I'm not, I don't have a set schedule. Sundays is laundry day and maybe some
bug boundaries if I feel like it, like if I have, you know, I have the time, but I want to have a day
where I don't have a schedule Monday through Friday. I have a schedule of like, I got to do calls
and all these things. And then Saturdays, like it's a mix of both, but I'm not putting the pressure on
myself to say, I have to work this Saturday. But if I go, Oh, I kind of want to do this right
now. It's work that I'm going to jump on and do it. So you want to have, you know, on my Sundays,
it's a no play, but Saturday is like, I'm going to work. I have, I play chess on Saturdays,
every Saturday I go and play this guy at a, at a coffee shop. I met him randomly like two months
ago. Now every Saturday I go play with him, but I make that time. I go, okay, if you're working,
at least take the time to go play chess with Roy, hang out with him and then go back to whatever you
were doing. Nice. Shout out to Roy. He'll never watch this, but shout out to that.
Shout out to Roy. Yeah. That's awesome, dude. Well, okay. So this isn't a great transition,
but I did want to talk a little bit about, cause you mentioned this in the beginning.
You mentioned that you saw like huge growth, uh, during one quarter, um, uh, of, of your,
of your journey. And I guess this kind of does play, play a little bit with like the motivation and
burnout aspects and stuff. Um, I'm looking at this, this photo that you put in the doc here and, uh,
uh, yeah, you had bounty stats right now. You're looking at Rachel.
Oh yeah. Bug bounty stats. Yes. Bug bounty stats. I mean, this spike in Q3 is bananas, right? It's like
twice your best quarter, other, like maybe even more than twice your best quarter. Otherwise.
Yeah. Um, can you tell me a little bit about sort of what, what happened there? Was there anything in
particular that, uh, change that sort of created that it was, it, is it sustainable to keep at that pace?
Like tell me a little bit about what, what happened in Q3. Um, a lot of things happened. So in, um,
November of 2022 is when I left my job and I was jobless and it was more of a, okay, well,
uh, time to find, I was thrown into like the, the dream that I had, like eventually working for myself,
not on my terms, but I was pushed to finally have to do this. Right. So naturally the first quarter,
I'm just going insane. What am I going to do? You know, I want to, what am I going to work on?
How am I going to make money? What am I going to do to like, enjoy what I do? All that stuff.
Q2 is, uh, so Q1 is just like planning, planning. These are my goals. I'm very much like
goal oriented. Like I have to write out my goals. Like how am I going to achieve them?
Uh, I wish I had this. Hold on. Let me show it to you.
I have this journal. If anyone wants to actually, you know, follow along and do this also,
I really recommend it. Um, it's called the best self journal and it allows you to set up three goals.
Uh, I'm not going to share those with you, but this is what a day to day looks like. It gives you this
page right here. It says today's goal, what you're grateful for today's three targets, your to-do list.
And what will make it be great. Dude, this rocks.
It is insanely cool. And let me see if I have an empty page of it. I can show you how you can set
up your goals. Um, so it lets you set up goals and it says like, how do you, you know, what is
this goal? What are the milestones for it? And that's how you plan it. So every week you plan it and
you put your goals right here and you go after it. I'm very much so I want to do this. So in Q2,
it was just more of a get it together for bug boundaries. Like, you know, if you wanted to do,
if you want to make decent amount of money, bug bounties is probably the easiest way to do it,
where you can make enough money to also not worry about your bills, but you are your launch your
company and do things. Q3 was when that came to reality because I started packing more on, um,
this bug bounty program. They did a lifehacking event with hacker one. And I also started collaborating
with people that I didn't collaborate with in the past, act more seriously collaborate. And then finally
finding the balance in Q3 between content hacking and what, what do I want to do? Like,
what do I want to do that I'm going to at least be happy? So I, you know, in the beginning of the
year, I was happy. I told myself if I make 80k this year, I'll be happy.
Mm. Yep.
But it's a scary thing because I've never done bug bounties like this, right?
Bug bounties was never my source of income. It was always like, I knew it was doable. I was just like,
okay, if I, no, sorry, it's not fair to say 80k, 80k was what I could do to be comfortably living.
So if I make 80k, I could comfortably live and pay my bills and not be, you know, not be stressed.
But that's what happened in Q3. A lot of it, it was more of a figuring out the balance, figuring out
the day to day that I told you, it's like, oh my God, this is working, you know, working on content in
the morning, gym, and then hacking is working. Collaborating with people like Zyad, Sean, and all
those other people really helped. So it's just figuring that out and just saying, okay, I'm going to keep
doing this until the rules fall off. Yeah. Okay. So then what, when I look at the graph, if I could
just follow up on that, I then see Q4. Now Q4 was second best quarter of the year, but what, what
did, did you sort of get more relaxed, like holidays and stuff? Like what was, did, you know, what, what
was the difference? Because it sounds like you kind of had figured it, figured out in Q3. So I was expecting
Q4 to be like the same or better, but I understand things happen. Well, no, with Q3, so I wasn't,
you know, with, with this specific program, we'll call it, with this program, I, I was hacking on
them before and I wasn't taking it serious. It was just like, okay, I'm going to make some money. And
you know, it's great. They're giving me some money here and there. Cool. I'm making, you know, a bounty
every week. Cool. But then H1702 happened. And a lot of people think like at H1702, I was hacking on like
some, you know, specific like app that no one had access to. Half of it is correct. I found something
that no one had access to, but also I realized like there is so much of this specific company
that you can hack on that you can't even wrap your head around it. It's such a ginormous company,
right? So Q3 is that realization. And then going from the H1702 event to Q4 is when I was like, okay,
time to double down on this company. There's people are making a ton of money. Why can't I do the same
thing? And Vegas was an example of it. When I came out of Vegas, it was just, I wrote that high
of Vegas for three months, dude. Yeah. That's awesome. I mean, I know that you like, you, once
you like, you know, you hit those goals, you're like, you know what, I'm going on a trip. I've been
doing my birthday. Like I was saying, and I was like, hell yeah, dude. So it's so well-deserved.
And I think you still actually like got a bunch more bounties after that too, right?
Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. But I just want to mention, like, it's, it's a lot of figuring things out,
like figuring out what work, figuring out what schedule worked for me, figuring out like,
holy, shout out this program, that's paying a lot of money. You can see the buildup. Q1,
they paid me a little bit of bounty. Q3 is when I was like, holy crap, like this is the reality of it.
I can make this money. You know, if I can make, you know, 30, 40 K a month from this bug bounty program,
that's a lot of money. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
A hundred percent. And, and, and I think it shows as well, it shows as well, you know, it took you a year
to crack that code, you know, you started in November, 2022 and then, you know, Q3, uh, of,
of 2023 is when this really, you know, started manifesting. And I'm looking at this chart as well.
This is the same chart that we talk about a lot. This is the submissions by severity or,
or submissions, you know, in a quarter period, um, from the hacker one performance, uh, tab.
Uh, and I'm seeing almost all of these are highs. There's, there's almost no mediums and no lows,
lows, and there's quite a few criticals, but the overall, the vast majority of these are highs.
Um, and I imagine that's because you sort of cracked the code on how to get a bug, you know,
qualified as a high on and, and that would really allow you to increase your earnings a lot because
every little mistake they make, now you figured out a way to work that into a high and you can repeat
that success over and over again. Is that, is that accurate?
It is, but it's also how they perceive a vulnerability, like what they, why they,
what they consider as a high, but also a lot of times it's just connecting things like saying,
okay, maybe like they call this the medium, but then you extend that to another application
and you can elevate that to a high, right? I'm trying to like, talk about these vulnerabilities
vaguely as I can. Um, but yeah, it's a, it's a lot of time just knowing if you prove one case to them
as a high, then everything else is considered as a high to them. It's the same root cause for them.
But some of these bugs were also, um, like things that I've never explained in the past. Like there
are, there are a couple of things that I never thought I could find in this company. Uh, it's
just going down a list of these vulnerable types and being able to go, I did this one, I did this one,
I did this one, I did this one, I did this one, um, and going through it.
Mm. Yeah. And, and I'm looking at the other, the other, you know, breakdown here, submissions
by weaknesses, and we're seeing a lot of XSS, seeing a lot of access control and a lot of IDOR as well.
Um, it, would you say that those are like, you know, the bread and butter for you as far as
vulnerabilities goes? And then I know XSS is such a huge category.
There's a big category, the, yeah, yeah. But there's also the no weakness type because a lot of those,
the no weakness ones are a chain of like different vulnerabilities.
Ah. And with the XSS ones, so like, I'll give an example for the XSS ones, if you,
so this is a mistake on my end. For example, if I RCE'd a desktop app because of the cost,
with the cost of scripting, the root cause is still cost of scripting.
Mm. Yeah. Right. So there's a couple of those that I, you know, there's, I want to say there's
like 10 of those that I like that. The root cause is still cost of scripting. The reality is
the cost of scripting, but it's just how you exploit it and how you, you know, show impact
to get more money. Um, some of them are like mobile related that I own the mobile app a couple of times,
but again, the root cause is cost of scripting again. So it's a lot of those things. It's just,
that comes through going to like finding out different contexts of vulnerabilities and how
they work in different areas of the, you know, this company, mobile apps, web apps,
desktop apps and stuff like that. Mm. Okay. This is, this is a little on the spot.
How many dupes did you get this year? Do you know?
Um, actually, can I check for that? Let me see. Yeah. Go, go, go ahead and check on that. And,
and I think, I think it's, uh, I think it's interesting that you highlighted that piece about
XSS because it is so, so like you're able to do so much with it. You can, you can escalate it in a web
context. You can try to pivot it to a, to a, a mobile app or to a desktop app. Um, and then even,
you know, just within the web context, you have a lot of ways that you can exploit with getting access
to session information, uh, cookie bombing, like there's, there's just very few other vuln types that
you can chain as well as an XSS to achieve some crazy stuff. So with the duplicates and it's loading,
you have to think about a bunch of them are duplicates of my own, like my own bugs also.
Right, right, right. That's tricky. Yeah.
So it's two pages worth. I'm assuming it's 25 a page or one page for 25. It's about less than 50.
Wow.
No, wait, there's more actually. There's, there's a third page. Hold on. There's three pages. So about
50 to 75.
Nice.
But there is a vast, there's a large number of them that's like, oh, you know, it's different
functionalities, but you know, it's the root cause it's the same, but yeah, about 75. And I don't,
uh, submission wise, I wish I had the number for how many I submitted, but I,
I think I submitted a lot this year.
Mm. Yeah. I think you can find that number, some, that number somewhere. And I think it
would be interesting to see the dupe to dupe to, uh, valid ratio.
Let me see what my triage and, yeah, let me see what my, uh, my triage and resolves are.
Yeah. Or you can say one of the easiest ways to do it is to do, uh, bounty awarded and then select,
you know, that, that date range within, within the filtering settings there.
Um, 146 is my number of closed as resolved and triage right now for 1, 1, 23 to 1, 1, 24.
Wow, dude. So, so you were reporting, you reported like 200, over, probably over 200 bugs in, in, uh,
in 2023.
Oh, 61 duplicates. There we go. The number for customers going to 61 duplicates and the 140 something,
that was my valid triage. Yeah. So right about 200 and 25, a little over 25%. Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
That's, that's pretty solid. That's amazing. So, so, you know, jumping off, off the back of that XSS
piece, one of the, the technical, you know, sections that we wanted to talk about while you were on here
is the blind XSS. Um, and I think that this is a category that not a lot of people specialize in.
So it's cool to have you come on the show and say like, yeah, blind XSS is kind of my thing.
Um, so can you talk a little bit about Ada's vulnerability class, perhaps just provide an
introduction to it and then, um, we'll kind of dive into what kind of payloads you're using,
what kind of platform, you know, you're using for that and custom mods to access payloads.
So, first of all, I don't consider myself to say blind XSS is my thing. I've just happened to be very
like blessed with it this year. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure.
Big portion of this also goes to, I gotta give a big shout outs to Z Shano for this specifically,
because he is, uh, also pushed me a lot or pushed my buttons also a lot to find more and more blind
cross-site scripting and just like bouncing ideas with me and, you know, just, you know,
going to him and venting to him sometimes. It's something with Zayed also, I guess,
gotta give them two, two, a shout outs before I start. But, um, blind XSS is just the same as your
regular stored XSS. I want to say a lot of times it's stored more than reflected, but the difference is
instead of it happening on the front app that you see, it happens on the backend where the company's
team sees it. So think about, you know, if HackerOne had a back portal, for example, where you can see
your reports, you know, the cross-site scripting payload that doesn't, you know, fire in the reports
section, but it fires in HackerOne's backend. Funny enough, if you look up, I actually had that happen
to HackerOne once. No way. While I was working there. Oh my gosh. That's amazing.
It says fire off an internal network at HackerOne. Uh, but yeah, it just, a lot of it is, uh, you just
learn that these companies make mistakes. They, the mistakes don't happen in the front end a lot
of times. It happens in the backend because they go, well, no one's going to ever see this and we
don't have to worry about it. And guess what? It does happen a lot more than you can expect.
And so I, that exact rationale was what I wanted to talk to you about. How do you identify
what pieces of information are going to end up in an admin panel somewhere?
You know, where, where do you get those ideas?
Uh, I think it's very, I want to say it's, I don't want to say it's common sense, but it's just very,
like, it's a thing that you think a company wants to collect on you. Right?
Yeah.
So when you register, what matters to that? You, that's your name, your email address, your address,
uh, your credit card information in some cases, anything that could identify you as a duplicate
account, for example, like they could say these are the same users. So that could be your browser
information, for example, and things like that. And then things that could also traces you, like
when you have different websites and things like that, right? It's how do they identify you as a
user and you as a browser or, um, you know, not the user itself, but like the, the,
I don't know, like the browser, for example, or the, or the device that we say, the device,
device. So those are the things that I look at. Right. Those are the things that I always assume
companies are collecting on you, but then also it goes, the information that you put in to the
company. So let's talk about, um, let's say like Spotify, for example, you guys post your podcast on
there, the description, the, the guests, the name of the, you know, you guys, and those are also
for sure they collect, but they could, you know, people probably find those XSS early on. And these
are those programs, but they don't think about like, oh, I wonder if this fires here, is it going to also
fire on the backend? And if it does, how do I get them to fire on that backend? Right? Those are the
things that you have to figure out. You have to assume, how do I go from A to B? Your A is I have
XSS on the core app. How do I get to fire on the backend? How do I get this engineer, the support
person without social engineering, naturally go click on it? Okay. So that's, that's where I was going
next with that was like, okay, so we've got information. We've put it in. We're using a blind XSS
payload that we can get a call back from. How do we, how are we going to be the one user that the
support agent clicks on or the, you know, backend analytics admin clicks on? I'm laughing because I,
I don't know how to say this. I don't want to tell me. I know. I know what you're going to say here.
Joel, what do you think I'm going to say? I want to tell you what you think.
Oh my gosh. We can cut this out if we need to.
No, go for it. Go for it. You just, you open a support chat and you say, Hey, I'm having an issue
with this thing. And you send it a link and they click it.
That is, that is, that is also, that's a very good approach, but no, the, I, I don't want to
promote committing fraud. I want to start with that. Yeah. But fraud detection is a big part of
technology. How do you get, what's the easiest way to get banned on a platform?
Right. What's the easiest way? What is the easiest way for them to be like, holy crap,
who is this guy? What do we do? What do we do to get rid of this person? Right. That is the number
one step. It's either fraud or too much traffic things like, Hey, look at me, like screaming,
like ban me. Number one step is get banned. Like that's the first step. Like, how do I get them to
go ban me? Right. This could be me reporting my own account with like 20 other accounts, for example.
Oh my gosh. I can just do that. Right. Yeah. So what Joel said is it's, it's, so first of all,
please don't go and hassle support people, but please don't do that to be real. But listen,
but there's a difference between saying, Hey, I have a problem. It's a legitimate problem that
causes an issue versus going like, Hey, click on this thing. I'm never asking the support stuff to
click on a link, but I am using the site like an actual like user. And I go, Hey, I can't find this
information. Where do I find it? And I go, Oh, I still can't find it. I really can sometimes.
Cause guess what? My page is broken. Like I have a script tag and that's broken. I'm not lying to
them. So I asked them like, Hey, could you set that information for me? That's it's a lightweight
social engineering, but I try to avoid as much as I can. A lot of times, a lot of these blind
assistance that I'm getting nowadays, isn't the support staff being included. It's me figuring out
these companies, how their processes work and what does it happen to get them to look into something
I do, whether it's like, you know, I put my credit card number in there, but the last digit is wrong.
A lot of times with, um, when you order something online, for example, they process that manually.
They check for your order manually sometimes, especially for your brand user. That's one of
the biggest things, dude. The number one thing that I used to do a couple of years ago was every single
time. Uh, John Baterini and I were sitting at, um, in a hotel one day. I love, I love John.
I look at him. I go, John, you want to make a thousand bucks today? He goes, what do you mean?
I go, let's make an order on this side. And he goes, what do you mean? I'm like, I'm banned,
but I bet you if you put this on this website with a blind context, something in the address,
the second address line, I promise you we're going to cross-text him when we wake up tomorrow.
He looks at me. He goes, bet we do it. The next morning we wake up. Sure enough. It's fine.
No way.
Fast forward, fast forward to five years later. This is this quarter, this last quarter.
I call him again and I go, John, you want to make some money, buddy? He's like, what do you got this
time, man? And I go like, you have an account on this particular site that I want to use. I'm banned.
Can you just go and do this? He goes, well, I have a problem with my account. I'm like,
perfect. That's even better. Can you try this? Sure enough, tries it. Another blind cross-text
thing starts off. It's just getting an understanding of how these companies work,
what requires them to manually have someone click on your page, and then you assuming this is the
information they're going to see about. I'm wondering, is there any merit to
sending your cross, like say it's like some sort of logging endpoint or something like that.
Is there any merit to sending it on a time-based basis? Okay, like every five minutes, we're going
to send another one through. Because whenever somebody first opens up the admin portal,
you know, there's always going to be like sort of like a page, a paginated list or something like
that. And if you land in that first, you know, 25 or whatever, then you might get in that front area.
Have you ever thought about that or any, tried anything like that? I haven't done it on purpose
because when you do stuff in the time manner, it's a little bit spammy. It is spammy.
It's the last thing I want is, but I've had that happen a couple of times. A couple of like fun
ones is it asks you for like a note sometimes. I put on the note, it doesn't fire. It doesn't
mean fire on their backend. They copy my note into an internal net, into the internal app for the track,
and then it fires, right? I've seen that happen before. The typical like in my email was a fun one.
One of the really cool one was a website. My password was a blank cross-screpting payload.
No, it was not. Oh my gosh.
This is just me copy pasting the same thing for my name, you know, email, everything. And then
the password was clear text.
Plain text.
No way. That's ridiculous, man.
That one hasn't happened. This was like eight, nine years ago. This was like, no, yeah, it's 2015,
2016. So six, seven years ago it happened. It's just, you know, you never know, right? You never
know. There's a couple of times where it's fired off in a engineer's like local machine because they
downloaded everybody's feedback and they were parsing it.
Yeah. That's crazy. That's so cool. And, and so with that, I kind of want to ask,
how do you track where your payload source was? Because what, what always happens to me when I
do blind XSS is all, is all tight, you know, throw this payload in there and then I'll get a call back.
And then I'm like, where did I put that in a form somewhere? You know? And then how do I record it?
Let me ask you a question. What are you doing for tracking? What are you using, like,
cost? Are you using like an XSS hunter? Yeah. I'm just using XSS hunter, normal XSS hunter.
Question number two. If you give, oh, okay. That's why. Oh, I don't know how that works.
Um, I don't know if truffle allows you to do this. Can you give it a path?
What, what do you, oh yeah. Like a specific path at the end? Oh, that's
your own path. You only get one path. Yeah. Oh, so see, this is what I do. I have my own domain.
Yeah. Uh, if you go to the London event, it was spammed everywhere. I think people like trolling me at some
point. Um, so I started deleting it, but I have a domain that is not a, it's a, it's a cross site.
It's a XSS hunter, um, JavaScript without the backend of XSS hunter. So it's just a JavaScript
that they have. Yeah. Um, and it, it just hooks into a PHP file and that PHP file is what processes the
entire, like when it fires, right? That's the backend is a PHP file. That's like garbage. It's
actually written by chat GPT. I shit you not. And then the, the, the front end of it, I have a
HTT access rule and in there that catches every single path you give and it serves that JavaScript
file if it, if it's not valid. So my 404 is that JS file that pops up. So when I do a cross, you know,
when I do a blind XSS, I do domain.com slash whatever I want to make a note of. So the note could be
first name and profile. That's an invalid path. So when it fires, it fires with, uh, my JS file and
it shows me where it's at. But a lot of times it's also easy to track because you know, it's something
like your name or, you know, your password and things like that. It's obvious. Uh, the feedback ones are
always the hardest one to track, but a lot of companies don't care where it came from because
they know where it came from. Yeah. They know where it came from. That's, that's really crazy. Yeah.
I mean, I can't imagine in scenarios where developers are like copy and pasting your
data into different applications or something like that, how you trace it back to the source.
It has to be done on the company side. I imagine. That one was a hard one because, um, yeah,
there was some issues with that one. I'd be like, oh, well you messaged RT. I'm like, no,
I didn't message anybody. They copy, pasted this dude. And I'm like, I did not say this to them.
And it turned out it was a note that I left. They copied the note into the internal app and then
fired. Wow. That's, that's crazy, man. What a, what a crazy hacking story.
Yeah. I know, I know your XSS Hunter instance, cause I know Mr. Sam McCreary likes to use it. And, uh,
I have my own XSS Hunter setup. That's not mine. That's not mine. That's not mine.
The only person that uses mine is, no, I think that's, uh, X. That's not mine. That's XS.
I also use that domain sometimes. Okay. You must be using your script. Cause I was looking through it and
there's like a bunch of like the Homsec references in the JS. It could be, it could be that, uh,
they're using a version of it. I shared that with everybody in you guys' group. Like I have no problem
with using it because it's not something I wrote. It's also like, I also saw Sean using it in a
specific way. I incorporated in mine, but the biggest thing that I have is the, the PHP file
on the backend. And, uh, me and Zyad have a, um, I can't actually say the name of our bot,
but I'll send you guys the name of the bot later, but we have a bot that we have created.
I almost said the name. It could have gotten me a lot of trouble, but, uh,
it's the, the name of the bot is the name of the CEO of the company. Okay.
So we have, we have a, and then the, the team has also seen this bot when I screenshot it for them.
That's so funny.
Uh, we have a, we have a bot that, um, it just says like, Hey everyone on, uh, in this score,
it's at everyone new blog and content scripting, and it gets the URL from that report. And then
also links to the report that I have as a text file. I store it all on my server. It's password
protected. You know, we have to have a credential to log into it and not just go look at it and then
analyze it and things like that. That system is one of the most.
Fucked up addicting things I've ever done because when I was getting a lot of
blogging scripting, dude, I was waking up at 5 AM rolling over and looking at my phone to see if a
new one popped up. And then when you see it popped and you can't go back to sleep.
Yeah. It's the same thing.
Yeah, dude. I just set up my own XSS Hunter and, um, I saw how yours was set up. Cause I thought it was
like standard and I really, I really like it. Cause I'm going to set up something to do the same thing
with like the path catch all and the subdomain catch all. Yeah, that's brilliant.
But here's, here's one more thing I gotta tell you guys with like just cross-starscripting in general.
I, by default, just use my blind XSS, um, payload everywhere because it also helps me track where
these fire. And then there's been times when somebody finds some like anomaly somewhere where
they're browsing the website and it fires. Like it didn't fire for me. Right. Like,
not on this app and then they found some weird page and I'd embedded and it fired. And like,
I get the notification now. And like you go with the mobile app, sometimes the mobile pages are
different, right? The path of the mobile page is different than what you saw on the web app.
And then you get a whole new place of like testing. So always, always use that for that reason.
Yeah. That, that makes a lot of sense.
What about CSP?
And, and I want to come back to that CSP thing, but real quick, I, this compares,
or this is sort of contrast with what we said before about using, you know,
H1 tags for your, for checking for XSS versus spraying around all of these, uh, blind cross-site
scripting payloads that by nature of cross-site scripting have to have some sort of callback,
either a JS or just an external resource callback. Yes and no.
How do you balance the two?
So yes and no. So when I'm looking for blind cross-site scripting,
Yeah. That whole, that whole methodology is out the window because I'm assuming it's going to fire
somewhere, right? When I'm looking for cross-site scripting, if it fires, then I go, okay, now how
do I get it to go from, from XSS to blind XSS? But when I, there's a, so how do I explain this?
There's times when I know most of these companies are, there's behavior you observe on an application.
Sometimes when you can tell somebody has reported a cross-site scripting here because now they're
filtering specific tags, right? But what they fail to do is look for blind cross-site scripting now.
So now my objective is just solely blind cross-site scripting. And with blind XSS,
you, you, you don't know, you just put your payloads in. But then what becomes interesting with
blind XSS is the assumptions you have to make with the context of where your payload is going to end up.
So I'm not just putting a image tag or a script tag, or I don't know, whatever tag you want to call it.
What does the payload look like?
I'm also thinking about, right. No, no. What is the, what is the, where is this going to get indexed
on the backend? Right. Because like, is if, if my name is being shown to me on my profile in, in a,
you know, it's not in a text area, right. More than likely where they see it is in an input
field or in a, in a box and a text area, because they have the ability to edit that. Right. So that in
mind, I have to think about where that's going to show up. Right. If, if I can put a, no, I can,
if I, if I can close the HTML tag in an input tag, should I just add an event handler for an example?
Like I have to think about all these different things. Right. So you have to think, where do I
put these? Do I put them before? Do I put them after? Does the, for the input tags, do I put it
before my actual payload? Do I close it first? There's all these different things you got to think about.
So are you doing that intelligently? Like, are you thinking, okay, this is where this is gonna,
okay. You are, you're not just using like a polyglot that has, you know, end text area. Okay. Wow.
That's, that's really interesting. And you had a lot of success with that.
So I test out this. Yeah. I test out the, I test out the theories, right? Like, first of all, like,
this is a, I don't know if this is unethical, but it is the reality of it. When you, when you're blind
cost transcripting fires, you have an advantage. Right. Because you have the entire DOM of that
page that you can look at. I'm not saying look for, you know, like ways to like explore their
vulnerabilities, but look at how that backend is created, dude. Are they using a lot of like
text areas? Are they doing a lot of like, what is the way they store data? And chances are they reuse
the same templates everywhere. Right. So you have the advantage, you know, this is what the backend looks
like once one fires and you see the, you know, where does my data go? Is it always going to be,
you know, in a title, is it going to be a script tag? Like, where is it going to go? You have that
advantage. That, that makes a lot of sense. Joel, swinging back around to the, um,
CSP related question. Go ahead. Sorry. Yeah. I was going to ask. So you mentioned that for blind access,
you use, um, XSS hunter, you know, payload or whatever. Yeah. Um, by the way, shout out to
mandatory for that. We gotta give him a big shot. Yeah. Legend. I mean, yeah, it's been like,
what a decade now and it still works. Um, yeah. So crazy. Um, but one thing that, that I, that has
always sort of puzzled me around how to exploit that successfully is the whole CSP aspect, which is
that basically like you're inserting an arbitrary script tag into a page. And even nowadays, like
script tags, especially loading from a URL, oftentimes we'll just get hit by, you know,
blocked by CSP or they just don't work in general. Why does it seem to sort of work in the blind access
contexts? I don't think a lot of these, like, so first of all, like with CSP one is like, I don't
know if CSP is there. Like, I don't even know if it's fine. I don't even know if it's fire. I'll
let me do that one more time. Now, you know, we have been on for a while, but, um, no, like with the
context of it, like you, you never, so I don't know if it's a CSP, I'm never going to see it. It's not going to
fire. Not my problem. Really. I'm not going to dwell on it. A lot of times I don't think companies,
maybe like Facebook and Google and all these companies implement CSP on their internal stuff,
but I don't think a lot of companies care. The whole thing is no one's going to see it. It's in our,
you know, it's in our private network. Threat model is different.
Threat model is different. Yeah. So a lot of times I've never, you know, I've any, there hasn't
been a company that I've tried blind access on, you know, minus the, the fan companies, for example.
Threat model. Um, most of those fan companies, like these, like, you know, the big ones that
don't have this problem. Right. But with the smaller ones, as I'm in a company where CSP was
an issue and I thought there's a CSP for some of those companies, when there is a CSP in the front
end, you can assume that there is going to probably be CSP in the back too, but that also turns out to
be not true in some cases. So, um, there is a graph I would like to do is the, the, the more you
F around, the more you find out. Yeah. And honestly, that's what I've done with bug bounties
do with like blind access system or you fuck around, the more you find out. So you have nothing
to lose to do that. You have nothing to lose to go report yourself as, as a spam or as a fraud or,
you know, your, whatever it is like reporting, for example, is a big one of those things.
You're not gonna, it's not gonna hurt. The only thing you have is to gain or it's because
you lose your account, you make another one, dude. That, that, that makes sense. And then,
and then from the CSS or CSP front, you know, I'm wondering if it would make sense ever to
submit more benign blind access, access payloads, like an image tag or like a, like a, you know,
style tag or, or something that's not necessarily going to, to get caught in the script source area
of the, of the CSP. And I know recently, um, uh, Gareth Hayes and the port swigger team released a,
uh, sort of a blind CSS injection framework where you can exfiltrate, you know, all of the contents
of the inputs and text areas and stuff like that. Um, do you have any theories on that? Do you have
any experience with non JS executed blind XSS? The, the thing with non JS executed is sometimes
you only have one shot to get this blind XSS to fire. That's true. I think you both know, I, I like
to gamble once in a while and I would rather just gamble on the XSS popping up than worrying about CSP,
because my only worry with that is if I get, um, you know, an image tag, for example, to pop up and
whatever it is, right. Then you have to prove to them that you also have JS to work. I don't want
to go down that path of like, you know, having to go through triage and telling them why this is
vulnerable and then explain to that engineer why this is vulnerable. Some companies don't get it.
So I'm going to gamble the fact that the JavaScript is going to execute and I have no
CSP issues. And when I, if I do, then screw it, I don't get paid for it. And I, I just never know.
Hmm. Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. Well, that, that, that was a positively intriguing
conversation surrounding blind XSS. I'm very interested in this and, and I'm, and, and, you
know, I had a phase of like, oh, I'm finding a lot of blind XSS and then I stopped looking for it.
And then it's great to talk with people, you know, about these sort of only really
types, cause it gets you re excited for it again. And, uh, I know there was a phase where everyone
was kind of putting them in their user agent and then all of the, the freaking, uh, you know,
WAFs and, and stuff started blocking everybody. And it was like, ah, this is just kind of a pain.
And it fell off the map for me, but, uh, this is definitely something I'm going to reintegrate
into my workflow again. Yeah, for sure. I think, um, I don't think blind XSS is going to go anywhere
for as long as XSS is around. I don't think the blind ones are going to go anywhere. So it's still an
issue. It's, you know, it's, I just want to like, you know, preface that if you are looking for XSS,
it's better to just use your own blind XSS payload than just a vanilla exploit, because
it also allows you to track and everything else. So it just makes it easier.
So just, just for the listeners, cause we, we had that all over the place in that conversation,
the setup that you've got is a JS file that X fills data out. You stole that from the, uh,
you know, mandatory payload or whatever. XSS Hunter. Yeah. XSS Hunter.
And then you've got a PHP file, a custom PHP file that will parse that out on your own server,
break that into a report, hit a, a discord callback. And that report is, is, you know,
hidden behind basic auth or whatever. So nobody can just log in and see the report.
Yep. Wow. Absolutely. I'll try to see if I can see the visuals. You can also put it in the,
in the bottom right here somewhere. Yeah. I would, I would, I would love to do that. Um, that, that,
that sounds like a really good system and something that would be really worthwhile doing. And then
the, the other thing that I wanted to ask about that specific thing is customer,
as far as customizations to the payload goes, are you exfiltrating, uh, local storage and, uh,
you know, anything you can, you can get access to beyond the normal payload or.
Um, Excelling has been trying to push me to do that a lot more. I haven't done any local storage
stuff. Mine is just,
send you mine. That'd be cool. But yeah, mine is, um, yeah, the only thing that I have on there is
I, I modify at the bottom. I sometimes have like a, you know, an alert sometimes, or also I have it like
from mobile apps, I have it dump stuff specific for that app, but no, the vanilla itself is just,
it's just commented out though. Like I take it out sometimes or I put it back on or I comment it out,
whatever it is, but just, I want to, the reason why I want to, um, tell you guys that again, use this
with everything that you test for XSS wise, because a, it helps you track all your volumes.
And so if you want to go back to them and see if you can bypass them, you have that in the context
of other applications, devices. Um, there has been a time where it happened on a device and I only had
one shot at this happening on the device. Like it popped up on an actual, like physical device.
It wasn't a mobile app. It wasn't, it was an actual like hardware. It popped up on there.
Right. And I couldn't modify the payload, but guess what? Because it was my JavaScript file,
I could modify it all I wanted to. So that gives you a huge advantage. The whole thing with XSS is
sometimes you get one shot, you know, and if it happens on a device, for example, you can modify
that, but you can modify your JavaScript payload. So keep that in mind when you do it.
That's awesome.
Yeah. The, the, that was excellent with regards to blind XSS. I'm hype about that. And the last thing
that we wanted to cover, cause I know we're, we're into the, uh, into the, well into the hour and a
half mark here, but you know, the, the intriguing ones always go a bit long. Um, uh, is we wanted to
discuss the going the extra mile on a bug bounty program to set up your environment. And this is
something that we talk about on the pod quite a bit. You know, we, we say pay the extra money to go and get
the premium feature, you know, go through the rigorous signup process. You need to get everything
set up. Um, could you tell me a little bit about your experience with that and why that's such a
pivotal part of your, your methodology?
Yeah. I mean, a lot of times I go in the extra mile could be the premium. It could be, um, so like,
I know a lot of people are scared of like, Ooh, I don't want to give them my ID. Cause what if it gets
hacked? Like I get that, like I'm with you, but there has been times when I've like ID verified
myself and I've gotten to open up to so much more stuff. I've sat on like, um, onboarding calls.
Uh, I've sat on like QA calls, like the customer service calls, uh, you name it, dude. Like it helps.
The other thing is like, it also goes as far as like customizing your, um, instance, right? Like
some of these companies allow you to like configuring everything. Yeah. Or styling everything. And
you know, there's all of these, like the more you give them, unfortunately that's the reality of it.
The reason, first of all, there's two things. One, they want your money or they want your data,
right? Like they want your money because you want to purchase something. So you pay them to open up
more stuff. Sometimes it's expensive. So you can't pay for it. Um, you can ask the companies,
they'll give it to you. But then the other one is like, sometimes I want to verify, like Airbnb is a big
one. You can't be a host without giving them your ID and stuff. A lot of hackers stop at that phase
because I don't want, you know, what if my company gets hacked? I don't want to have my information.
I don't want to have my social, but you have to do those things because it opens up a lot of more
stuff. Um, but also keep in mind of like, again, I want to say the whole, like the ROI of your time.
If you are, if a company is maybe giving you 1000 for a critical, maybe not worth it unless you're like,
you know, ask instead of, you know, you're going to be able to go for a quantity of criticals
than this, that is worth it. But if a company is like 25 K max or even 10 K max, right? That is
still worth it. That is the return in your time. You know, there was a company that I hacked on that
required me to send them a bunch of letters. I got to actually shift letters to them. And I spent
like three days in the post office with this company, dude. No way. Oh my gosh. I did it.
And it gave that a really good bug, right? Um, my tax documents right now, every year I get them as a
script tag inside of it. Like, because I went into this company as my taxes and a bug bounty program,
I paid them to do my taxes one year. I did all that stuff. Right. I've gone as far as like opening
retirement accounts with particular companies. No way. That's amazing. So like, it's not that I'm
like, you know, I'm trying to, I was thinking about, I go, oh, I'm going to retire. I'm going to open a
retirement account. Right. Who should I do it with? I think about these companies that are big,
that have a bug bounty program that I can also test out. Right. You want to invest money, like all these
different things. Like, think about it. Like it's always the mentality of how you are a hacker too.
I'll never forget this time where you and I were collaborating on a, uh, on a target where you could
open up a credit card with this target. And, uh, you, you gave me access to your, to your credit card.
You're like, here, just, I want you to buy a credit card. I had their most expensive credit card. I had
their checking account and like two other services with them too, dude. And I didn't open up their most
expensive credit card cause I wanted it. It was because of that event, dude. Yeah.
And I really wanted to see what that company had. And I was like, I was like, dude, why the heck are
you doing this? And, but at the same time I was telling you like about all of these, uh, you know,
benefits I was getting from signing up for these, you know, credit cards and then, you know, doing the
point hacking thing. And you're like, bro, you know, if we find one bug, you're going to get so much
more value out of this than all of these like credit card hacking points, things you're doing.
The maximum thing you pay, the maximum you pay for a credit card is like $700 a year. Yeah.
Yeah. $700 is probably the one that I pay the most. The maximum bounty you can get from a company
that size is what? Like 15, 20 K? Yeah, for sure. At least.
Right. So I mean, also like the chicken count is free. So who cares? The credit card, I wanted that
credit card at some point and then the program pushed me, but those are just like things to think
about. Right. Like if you're making an order with a company that's a bug bounty program, think of like,
oh, what else can I do with this? Um, so yeah, that's the biggest thing to it, man. Like you just
got to think about like, I'm going to make this decision for my personal life. Obviously don't
base it all on your bug bounty experience, but if you have the option and you think, you know,
you're deciding between two companies when I was a bug bounty program, I'm going to go with that one.
So I can also test it out. Yeah. Yeah. So you can test it. And also just because you know,
it's going to be more secure as well, you know, like people are in there testing on it every day.
So there's, there's value to that. Um, Ben, dude, this has been legendary, man. Thank you so much
for coming on and sharing all this knowledge. And, and I'm so glad to see the, you know, completed
rise from, from the low lows to the high highs after, after doing, you know, half a million bug
bounty and really crushing the video scene and seeming much more happy and stable. And, uh, it's
really, it's really inspiring, man. Yeah, of course. And kudos to you guys for, you know, making such a good
podcast and staying consistent and bringing so many amazing guests. Yeah. Thank you guys for having me and
I'm excited to see what else you guys put out for sure. Thanks man. Absolutely dude. Yeah.
That's the fun. Peace.